[Applause]
okay let's start with number 129 before
we head over to the virtual Press Room
yes if you could just say you're oh for
the microphone and if you could when you
get your microphone if you wouldn't mind
saying your outlet and Country please
USA
blackfilm.com Jay Carter how are you
well thank you congratulations oh man
what a win this is a tough this is a
tough uh lineup of uh best costume
design so I'm really happy for my
colleagues as well because they deserve
the nomination and they also deserve to
win
so my question is doing a movie of this
magnitude
how do you make the costume part of the
movie instead of becoming the movie
well you know
I love costumes so that's really hard
for me
um but you know it's about storytelling
you don't want to distract you don't
want to you want to support and I enjoy
supporting actors I enjoy shepherding
them to the set in a costume that they
feel good in that they can perform in so
I never wanted to overshadow the story
or the performance I'm here to support
and it's a collaborative medium
all right let's move over to the virtual
Press Room so we have up your geek which
we will follow with number uh 258 so up
your geek
hi
up here hi this is uh blue book or up
your geek
uh I wanted to know about your process
and designing the costumes uh for Queen
ramunda
um uh what did you I I know you did this
for the first film did you take any
different steps in the second film when
designing this uh the costume yes uh the
first film we were introduced to Queen
Ramona as the queen as the support to
t'challa uh in wakanda Forever were
introduced to her as the ruler of
wakanda so we stepped up we we enhanced
um Angela always wanted to play a queen
and so to amplify her as the ruler of
wakanda we added vibranium more
vibranium we added an extra uh an extra
element to her ishikolo the the married
woman's crown that she wears we gave her
the Royal color of purple and adorned in
gold as she enters the U.N in this gown
and and it was incredible to to elevate
Queen Ramona to this new status and so
the process was to give her strength and
show also the the the way that she uh
embodied her place in wakanda as you can
see on the uh in the film when she sits
on the throne she's in a gray one
shoulder dress yes and the one through
the exposed shoulder shows her strength
because you know Angela she got those
guns right so we exposed her arms we
exposed her arms at the in the U.N to
show you know how beautiful women can be
how strong and vulnerable at the same
time but also can lead the nation
okay and next up we have three eight
five before moving over to three two
three so number three eight five
hey Ruth it's Jazz from variety okay
Jeff hey congratulations on the win
thank you Ruth you have just made
history by becoming the second woman to
Second black woman to win an Oscar ever
and the second one black woman to win in
the category of costume design how can
you make history by being the second you
you've you've just made Oscar history
and we're so excited but what does your
win mean tonight
uh listen I I pulled myself up from my
bootstraps I started you know single
parent uh household I wanted to be a
costume designer I studied I I scraped
you know I dealt with adversity in the
industry that sometimes didn't look like
me and I endured so I I feel that this
win opens the door for other young
costume designers that you know may not
think that this industry is for them and
hopefully they'll see me and they'll see
my story and they'll think that they can
win an Oscar too
okay next up we have two five eight and
our last question will be three two
three uh John Boone from A-frame
congratulations Ruth uh right here all
right thank you um you dedicated the win
to your mom what did how did she react
when you won your first Oscar and what
do you think she would think of you
coming home with a second one
um my mom passed away last week and
um I had a great relationship with her
in her final years the same relationship
that I've always had with her I was her
ride or die I was her Road dog I was her
sidekick and uh she always wanted me to
follow my dream even after I graduated
from college and I came back home to do
an internship and I didn't quite know
where I wanted to step next and I packed
up my Volkswagen Rabbit and my mother
said you don't want to stay here you can
just go so I know she's proud of me I
know that she wanted this for me as much
as I wanted it for myself
thank you and last question three two
three
hi Tanya Hart American Urban Radio
Networks congratulations thank you uh
you do so much to give back that people
don't know about but I understand that
some sbcu students helped you design I
think what you have on today could you
tell us about that well not this dress
but when he did do an HBCU dress
challenge for the NAACP image Awards and
the costume designer skilled Awards
where I wore their designs they were
young uh African-American fashion
students at an HBCU called pencil Lewis
college and this one is my creation
thank you
okay wonderful thank you so much Ruth
Carter thank you